[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
february is here yet again but the video
game industry is
still in their winter slumber i was
looking forward to telling you about
outriders a cover shooter crossed with a
looter shooter and also
ryder's republic an extreme sports mmo
and far cry 6's huge return but all
three of those games have been delayed
so we'll talk about them later in the
year with these
aaa games moving aside we can highlight
other games including three
free-to-play games so let's do this
have you heard of little nightmares it's
a puzzled platformer with horror vibes
back in 2017 the original game released
and struggled to find its audience even
though it had many eights and nines out
of ten in review scores
on february 11th the sequel arrives
little nightmares does not include a
single word of dialogue
there are occasional grunts but
everything is experienced through the
actions
of a little girl in a yellow raincoat
this time around she is joined by a boy
wearing a brown bag on his head as a
mask and the two work together
to navigate through pale city the game
is short but this is reflected in the
price point which is less than half the
price of a typical game in most
countries
if you don't think this is the game for
you i urge you to try the free demo out
now
most of the footage right now is from
the 20 minute demo and
instantly you'll get a feel for the
little nightmare's atmosphere which is
so difficult to explain
little nightmares 2 drops on february
11th on playstation xbox switch
and pc
speaking of a dude with a box on his
head next we have a brand's banking new
game
which is being released free on
playstation plus
this is destruction all stars let's get
something out of the way quickly here
destruction all stars is a ps5 exclusive
title which even those on ps4 cannot
play
but if you plan to grab a ps5 in the
future i recommend downloading the
playstation app on your phone
and adding this game to your library
when it releases on february 2nd
it will be waiting for you when you
finally switch to a ps5
no rush the game itself is a destruction
derby of sorts with players smashing
vehicles until a winner is proclaimed
the kicker is each driver is armed with
different abilities
to use to their advantage i have to
admit this looks like a great deal of
fun
but to only release on ps5 with quite a
small user base at the moment
could be a tough start for this game the
art style looks
engaging and fun the characters are
unique and when your car
is vaporized we can run around on foot
sounds like a dreadful idea i can't wait
to try it
releasing on playstation 5 for free on
ps plus on february 2nd
before going full price two months later
let's stick with free games and here's
one that doesn't require an online pass
to access
auto chess remember when auto chess
looked to be taking over the world
and then completely vanished from
existence well it's back again here's
the premise
auto chess is a combination of chess and
tower defense
and mobas yeah it's a weird game genre
but stick with me
you may have already seen the first auto
chess played in star wars by the way
back in the 70s the auto part of the
title is simple too
once the game begins everything is
automated
our job is to build up a deck of
characters to use on the board
which are determined by stats and simply
watch as they scrap
it out the characters have a level of
randomization to add a look element and
focuses us all on knowing
all potential builds of a team to truly
master auto
chess auto chess has been in early
access for about eight months now but on
january 27th
it is in full release on both ps4 and
ps5 completely for free
and it joins mobile and pc versions
they're free as well
there is also a switch version coming
very very soon we are told
could auto chest be the genre you've
been looking for give it a go
it's free after all
about a year ago we looked at a game
called cuisine royale
remember it a battle royale title which
started out as a joke between
friends using pots and pans as armor and
magical boots to leap into the air
well check it out now as of last month
cuisine royale has been revamped
and relaunched as a cursed foad or
cuisine royale second edition
fulfillment of all desires
rolls off the tongue i prefer calling it
christoford the game is going down a
mythical road right now with seasonal
updates which have brought in a thor
style viking
shamans and nuns with rocket launchers
the core game loop remains the same it's
the last person standing wins the game
but as this is a rebrand and a relaunch
i thought i'd spread the word
i personally haven't tried the update
yet please let me know if it's any good
cursed board is available right now on
playstation xbox and pc
[Music]
one last free to play game to get on
your radar this month
roller champions i'll be brief here
there is still no release date past
q1 2021 which means it will be here in
either
march or february as there are so few
games dropping this month
we may see roller champions take
advantage of this lull and release
in february fyi roller champions is a
roller derby style
sports game in which a ball is carried
around and thrown into a goal
more loops round more laps completed and
the ball is worth more points
but all the while the enemy can forcibly
take the ball from you
and score their own goal knowing my luck
this game will be delayed so let's not
dwell on this one right now
but at the moment it's releasing in
february or march
keep an eye out for it
take a look at this werewolf the
apocalypse earthblood
an action role-playing game set in a
sinister world
and as the title suggests we play as a
werewolf
our character can freely change into a
wolf to move around the world quicker
with a lower profile there are three
forms which affect different play styles
the human form is for social and
interaction elements in the world
the wolf form is for exploration and
infiltration
and then there's this form the chronos
form for
combat scenarios and yeah that's the
werewolf you were thinking
about at the start wasn't it kahal is
known as an eco warrior in this world
and looks to expose and close the evil
corporations around the world like the
ones digging for oil
werewolf the apocalypse earthbound
releases on february 4th
on playstation xbox and pc
[Music]
any nintendo fans around here super
mario 3d world and bowser's fury arrive
on february 11th
but you already knew that right it's
more mario what's not to love there and
finally
persona 5 is back again again again the
series which quietly keeps on churning
out content and building up a massive
fan base
this is persona 5 strikers a break from
the core series
strikers is all about hack and slash
action with rpg elements
set six months after the end of persona
5 we follow joker and the phantom
thieves crew as they investigate a
series of strange and compelling
scenarios
and along the way everything will just
become button bashing mayhem
it's great the game released a year ago
in japan
and now on february 23rd the rest of the
world will be able to play this
on ps4 switch and pc
so there we go seven new games coming in
february 2021 we're at the slowest time
of the year for video game releases but
things will be heating up soon with
games like return
and monster hunter rise appearing in
march i'll be back next month to tell
you about those titles
and there's some more free to play games
coming in march so watch this space
i'm adam from playstation grenade you're
awesome i'll see you next time
you